actor chadwick boseman
has died at the age of 43. a statement
was released on chadwick's official
social media accounts
which reads it is with immeasurable
grief
that we confirmed the passing of
chadwick boseman
chadwick was diagnosed with stage 3
colon cancer in 2016
and battled it with these last four
years as it progressed to stage four
a true fighter chadwick persevered
through it all
and brought you many of the films you
have come to love so much
from marshall two to five bloods august
wilson's
ma rainey's black bottom and several
more all were filmed during and between
countless surgeries and chemotherapy
i am not ready to be without you it was
the honor of his career to bring
king t'challa to life in black panther
he died in his home with his wife and
family by his side the family thanks you
for your love and prayers
and asks that you continue to respect
their privacy during this difficult time
among many iconic roles chadwick was
perhaps
best known as his role in black panther
in the marvel cinematic universe
this whole marvel thing is just like it
doesn't make any sense like you feel
like you're walking around in a dream
chadwick's friends fans and co-stars
were shocked by the news
with countless tributes pouring in just
minutes after the news broke
he was set to star in the black panther
sequel in may 2022
this experience you know it's
hard to explain it until you see it but
this experience will be different than
any other you've seen that's for sure
the themes the conflicts will be things
that
superhero films have never touched on
before
this cast is one that you've never seen
before marvel was brave enough to have
this
black cast mostly black cast so this is
an experience you've never seen before
for reasons i cannot even say now more
than ever
the illusions of the vision threaten our
very existence
we all know the truth more connects us
and separates us but in times of crisis
the wise built bridges while the foolish
build barriers we must find a way
to look after one another as if
we were one single tribe
you